[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
halallweg guten Abend und willkommen
alles Wichtige vom Fußball hat nachher
nort leemmann einen schön guten Abend
auch von mir schauen wir auf die
Nachrichtenthemen von
heute Haushaltsberatungen abgesagt die
Ampel ringt weiter mit den Folgen des
Karlsruher
Urteils Geiseln gegen Häftlinge Israel
und Hamas verständigen sich auf ein
Abkommen das auch eine mehrtägige
Feuerpause
beinhaltet und dfb1 vor Scherbenhaufen
bei der 0 Z2 Pleite in Wien zeigen sich
die deutschen Fußballer nicht
em-tauglich wir beginnen mit der
Haushaltskrise die weiter brodelt
eigentlich wollte die ampelregierung
morgen den etentwrf 2024 festzuren doch
daraus wird nichts zu groß die
Unsicherheiten um die Milliardenlöcher
die sich aus dem Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts ergeben genaue
Zahlen hat derzeit offenbar niemand aber
der Bundesrechnungshof geht nach dem
Karlsruher Urteil davon aus dass die
Ampel im laufenden Jahr ihren zulässigen
Kreditrahmen um knapp 140 Milliarden
überschritten hat das wäre fast ein
Drittel des gesamten Haushalts
2023 im nächsten Jahr kämmen noch mal
48,5 Milliarden dazu Frank
buchwalte Geld und Verstand beide sind
nützlich besonders im Bundeshaushalt so
warb das Finanzministerium bisher für
die Schuldenbremse die aber wackelt wie
nie zuvor per Talkshow schickt der
Vizekanzler nun offene Avancen Richtung
Union Verantwortung kann man ja auch in
der Opposition ausüben deswegen würde
ich mich freuen wenn wir einen Modus
finden würden wo wir uns
gegenseitig helfen oder stützen und ich
würde auch darauf wetten dass bei einem
nächsten Wahlkampf die Menschen in
Deutschland klug genug und
wahrscheinlich auch lösungsorientiert
genug sind dass sie diejenigen die jetzt
die Lösung präsentieren wählen im
adenauerhaus aber setzen sie offenbar
andere Prioritäten der Parteichef
reagiert kühl die Zeit wo man
Transformation durch Subventionen die
mit Schulden finanziert werden machen
will ist vorbei die Ampel massiv unter
drruck zumal auch das Murren bei der FDP
lauter wird ein Mitglieder Entscheid für
ein Ende der Koalition hat das notwendig
Quorum erreicht das setzt den Parteichef
unter Zugzwang Lindner gestern Abend zum
Krisengespräch beim Kanzler auch die
Haushalte für dieses und das nächste
Jahr stehen mittlerweile im Ruch
verfassungswidrig zu sein Olaf Scholz
hat am Abend Italiens Regierungschefin
Meloni zugast zum Haushalt keine Details
jedoch klar ist dass wir die ökologische
Transformation hinbekommen die wichtig
ist für unsere globale
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit und für den Schutz
des Klimas und insofern glaube ich ist
bei allen der Ehrgeiz und der Wille da
das gut und richtig zügig aber nicht
überhastet zu machen am
Finanzministerium haben sie das Plakat
inzwischen abgeklebt die Werbeaktion sei
beendet dabei wurden Geld und Verstand
in Berlin selten dringender gebraucht
als heute tun ber in Berlin wie geht's
denn jetzt weiter auf jeden Fall mit
Überstunden für den Bundestag und für
den Bundesrat denn klar ist es braucht
auf jeden Fall noch eine Sondersitzung
vor Weihnachten wahrscheinlich in der
Woche vor Weihnachten ten und
möglicherweise sogar zwischen den
Feiertagen hören wir hinter den Kulissen
sonst klappt es vielleicht nicht mit
einem Haushalt für 23 und 24 und das ist
eben auch nur die Variante wenn sich die
Ampel einigen kann es gibt auch noch die
Variante dass die Ampel keine Lösung
findet bis zum Jahresende dann müsste
sie erst einmal eine vorläufige
Haushaltsführung durchführen das
erlaubtes Grundgesetz damit die
Verwaltung weiter am Laufen bleibt und
damit die Bundesregierung mindestens
rechtliche Verpflichtungen erfüllen kann
das ist aber der Fall den hier alle
erstmal vermeiden wollen und deswegen
gibt es hinter den Kulissen eine Menge
Arbeit aber garantieren will uns heute
auch keiner dass eine Lösung tatsächlich
bis zum Jahresende da ist also viel ist
noch offen danke schön nach Berlin
chakunta la
benergy
Planungssicherheit das fordert jetzt die
Wirtschaft von der Politik die
Unternehmen fürchten dass nach dem
Karlsruher Urteil Milliardenhilfen
ausbleiben z.B für die besonders
energieintensive
Stahlindustrie denn jetzt wackelt die
von der Regierung geplante Entlastung
bei den Strompreisen und die Förderung
für die Produktion von grünem Stahl mit
Hilfe von Wasserstoff könnte wegfallen
ein riesenprem für die Branche Susanne
Freitag cateron
berichtet der Stahlriese Tissen kup
musste heute massive Verluste vermelden
dazu kommt nun der Schock der
Haushaltssperre die Animation zeigt wie
die Zukunft gedacht war sauberer grüner
Stahl im Sommer gab ist die Förderzusage
über 2 Milliarden Euro immerhin dieses
Geld ist sicher die Folgeinvestitionen
aber sind es nicht im saahand ist die
Lage noch angespannter Saarstahl will ab
2027 mehrheitlich grünen Stahl
produzieren über 3 Milliarden
investieren aber der Förderbescheid aus
Berlin ist noch nicht da alles steht auf
dem Spiel es gibt keinen Plan B dann
wird das Saarland nicht dekarbonisiert
und dann wird's hier langfristig keinen
Stahl im saarand
geben deshalb gingen im Oktober Tausende
auf die Straße sie machten Druck damit
Berlin die Fördergelder genehmigt eine
mündliche Zusage des
Wirtschaftsministers gab es das reicht
aber nicht dort wo lediglich
unverbindliche oder gar nur mündliche
Zusagen herrschen das ist natürlich
nicht rechtsverbindlich das heißt das
steht jetzt alles zur Disposition die
Unternehmen die können bloß hoffen dass
das eingehalten werden kann aber es
müssen ja bis zu 60 Milliarden eben auch
eingespart werden die saarländische
Ministerpräsidentin t die Schuldenbremse
es kann ja nicht das Ergebnis sein dass
wir ganz wunderbar auf die Einhaltung
der Schuldenbremse geachtet haben aber
bei der Gelegenheit die Wirtschaft in
Bach runtergeht und tausende von
Menschen um ihren Arbeitsplatz fürchten
müssen zahlreiche
transformationsprojekte der deutschen
Industrie stehen jetzt wieder auf dem
Prüfstand jetzt zu einem Lichtblick im
Nahen Osten nach fast 7 Wochen Krieg und
Verzweiflung schon morgen sollen die
ersten von 50 Geiseln aus der gew der
Hamas freikommen Frauen und Kinder wer
genau ist noch unklar im Gegenzug sagte
Israel vier Tage Waffenruhe zu außerdem
die Freilassung von 150 in Israel
Inhaftierten Palästinensern
lpot noch wird mit voller Kraft gekämpft
Israels Armee griff heute
hamasstellungen im Zentrum und Süden des
Gazastreifens an dabei wurden mehrere
Menschen getötet in der Nacht hatte das
israelische Kabinett einer Feuerpause
und einem Austausch von hamasgeiseln
gegen palästinensische Häftlinge aus
israelischen Gefängnissen zugestimmt ab
morgen früh sollen die Waffen ruhen aber
nur vorübergehend betonte der
Regierungschef wir werden den Krieg
fortsetzen bis wir alle Ziele erreicht
haben Hamas ausschalten alle Geiseln und
Vermissten nach Hause bringen und
sicherstellen dass von Gaza keine Gefahr
mehr für Israel
ausgeht Gillard Korngold ist froh aber
er bankt weiter um sieben seiner
Familien angehögen in der Hand der Hamas
darunter zwei Enkel und D Jahre
alt es sind 40 Kinder als Geiseln in
Gaza freigelassen werden jetzt nur 30 wo
sind die anderen ich weiß es nicht ich
hoffe alle werden
freigelassen angespannt wartet auch
hadas Calderon Mutter von zwei
kindergeiseln auf die gute
Nachricht solange sie nicht mit eigenen
Augen sehen sie umarmen kann kann ich es
noch nicht glauben bei den palästinens
im gaz en hoffen sie auf ein baldiges
Ende des
Kriegs wir beten für die Feuerpause wir
brauchen dringend Frieden hier damit die
Menschen wieder nach Hause können zur
Arbeit gehen
können als Teil der Vereinbarung sollen
mit Beginn der Feuerpause morgen auch
umfangreiche Hilfslieferungen aus
Ägypten in den Gazastreifen gebracht
werden Michael beberunge in Tel Aviv wie
wird die Vereinbarung in Israel
aufgenommen
heute überwiegt natürlich Erleichterung
dass ein großer Teil der geisern
freikommen soll und die Hoffnung darauf
dass noch mehr folgen werden aber es
bleiben auch gemischte Gefühle das
beginnt damit dass nur 30 der 40
bekannten kindergeiseln freikommen
sollen von den anderen ist offenbar noch
nicht mal der Standort bekannt und die
Israelis ahnen dass nicht alle Geiseln
wahrscheinlich lebenfi kommen werden
wenn die israelische Armee ihr Feldzug
gegen die Hamas bis zum bitteren Ende
durchführen wird die Hamas wird sich bis
zum Schluss ein faustpfan behalten
geiselnamen sind eines der größten
traumat der israelischen Gesellschaft
und dieses geiseltrauma ist das
Schlimmste dass die Israelis je erlitten
haben danke schön nach telaviv Michael
Bunge wenn die wichtigsten Länder der
Welt über wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit
sprechen heißt die Formel für das
Treffen G20 ne den großen persönlichen
Treffen der Staats- und Regierungschefs
gibt es auch virtuelle Begegnungen sowie
heute Gastgeber war Indien aus Moskau
dfte sich auch russlands Präsident Putin
zuschalten Kanzler Scholz rief ihn dazu
auf die Invasion der Ukraine zu beenden
Armin ker
berichtet es soll aussehen als ob gar
nichts gewesen wä Vladimir Putin beim
virtuellen G20 Gipfel das Format wie für
ihn gemacht alle reden nacheinander
keine Diskussion kaum Distanzierung
niemand kann Putin Einhalt
gebieten einige Kollegen haben ja
bereits gesagt sie sein geschockt über
Russlands andauernde Aggression in der
Ukraine ja selbstverständlich ist jeder
Krieg eine Tragödie und wir müssen Wege
finden die zu
beenden dass er den Krieg begonnen hat
spart Putin aus stattdessen täuscht er
Verhandlungsbereitschaft vor konkret
wird er dabei nicht auch nicht bei
seinen Einlassungen zur
Weltwirtschaft die Zuspitzung der
chronischen Probleme im weltweiten
Finanzsektor der Energie und
Ernährungssicherheit verschärfen sich
Putin als Problemlöser die Inszenierung
scheint knallhart kalkuliert denn
während die ukrainische Gegenoffensive
stockt und der Nahostkrieg den Westen
davon abzulenken droht versucht ein fast
freundlicher Putin den besten zu testen
und kann dabei durchaus auf Unterstützer
zählen z.B Indien premier Modi sitzt
gerade den G20 vor Indien ist der größte
Abnehmer von russischen Rohstoffen und
Indien bereitet Putin die Bühne der hat
die Welt schon oft an der Nase
herumgeführt und der versucht es heute
einmal
mehr mehr zum Treffen der mächtigen mit
Putin gibt's auch um 19:30 Uhr bei ZDF
heute live zu sehen in der heute App und
in unseren Social Media
Kanälen spannende parl in den
Niederlanden der bisherige
Regierungschef rütte zieht sich nach 13
Jahren im Amt aus der Politik zurück und
es ist völlig offen wer ihm nachfolgt
die besten Chancen haben die Partei des
Rechtspopulisten Wilders die
rechtsliberale Volkspartei mit
Spitzenkandidatin jeschel Göss und das
rotgrüne Bündnis unter dem früheren
EU-Kommissar timmermns die Wahllokale
schließen um 21
Uhr das Bundesverfassung gericht hat
drei ehemaligen Abiturienten aus Bayern
Recht gegeben die drei haben eine Lese
und rechtsschreibstörung die das Gericht
als Behinderung anerkennt sie sahen sich
diskriminiert weil auf ihren Zeugnissen
stand dass ihre Rechtsschreibung nicht
bewertet worden war grundsätzlich aber
dürfe es auf Zeugnissen Vermerke geben
wenn einzelne Leistungen wie z.B die
Rechtschreibung bei der Benotung außer
Acht gelassen werden so das Gericht
allerdings müsse das dann für alle
Schüler und Schüler mit Behinderung
gelten nicht nur für
legasttheniker trotz Rechtsanspruch es
gibt zu wenig kitaapätze bei uns und die
wenigen begehrten Plätze sind auch noch
ungleich verteilt sagt eine neue Studie
insgesamt geht nur die Hälfte der ein
und zweijährigen in eine Kita deutlich
weniger sind es wenn die Familie
armutsgefährdet ist ohne akademischen
Hintergrund oder wenn dort überwiegend
kein Deutsch gesprochen wird warum das
so ist und und welche Folgen das hat
berichtet Petra
Otto sie essen zusammen und lernen
voneinander hier im Kindergarten
waldpforte in Mannheim egal ob ihre
Eltern viel oder wenig verdienen und
welche Sprache zu Hause gesprochen wird
doch die neue kitstudie belegt gebildete
deutschprechende Familien Kriegen im
Schnitt viel leichter ein Platz sie
wissen dass man sich bei mehreren Kitas
anmelden kann sie wissen sehr viel eher
dass es ein Kita Rechtsanspruch gibt die
haben nicht so viele Schwierigkeiten bei
der kitaitas Suche wie Familien die
grundsätzlich nicht so privilegiert sind
Benachteiligung geht also schon los vor
der Einschulung im Kleinkindalter schaut
mal ein Sattel ein Sattel genau wenn man
jetzt gerade an die Sprache denkt ja da
haben nicht alle Kinder den gleichen
Entwicklungsstand und hier in unsakita
sind wir natürlich gut ausgebildete
Fachkräfte die dann auch die
entsprechenden Methoden haben um diese
Kompetenz bei den Kindern zu stärken
weniger Kita Kinder aus sozialschwachen
Familien das liegt auch an der Nachfrage
kitait sein zu teuer die Öffnungszeiten
schlecht Resultat die Mütter bleiben zu
Hause das zweite Einkommen fehlt wir
müssen uns darum kümmern wie jedes Kind
gute Bildungschancen hat damit wir auch
nachhaltig und in 20 Jahren die
Fachkräfte haben die wir brauchen mehr
Kitas gute Ausbildung von Erzieherin und
eine gerechte Verteilung der Plätze eine
Investition die sich lohnt für Kinder
Eltern fürs ganze
Land was kluge Köpfe entdecken können
das zeigt jedes Jahr der deutsche
Zukunftspreis soeben kürte der
Bundespräsident die Gewinner ein
Forschungsteam aus Erlangen sie haben
ein MRT entwickelt das sehr viel simpler
und günstiger ist als die bisherigen
Geräte Petra Neubauer hat mehr ob Räumer
Krebs oder Erkrankungen inner Organe für
eine verlässliche Diagnose ist eine
Magnetresonanztomographie kurz matt
immens wichtig aber die Scanner heute
sind sehr groß und schwer sie sind sehr
teuer sie sind komplex in der
Infrastruktur und sie sind schwierig zu
bedienen um das zu ändern entwickelten
die Forscher um Stefan biieber ein
System das mit einem kleineren Magneten
auskommt und mit Hilfe eines KI
gestützten bildverfahrens dennoch hoch
aufgelöste Bilder liefert zudem
verwenden Sie ein neues Kühlsystem für
den Magneten das braucht statt 1000
Liter des teuren Heliums weniger als
einen Liter und durch den kleineren
Magneten bleibt mehr Platz für den
Patienten bedeutet Röhren mit größerem
Durchmesser wir haben viel weniger
Probleme mit Platzangst bei erwachsenen
Patienten und wir haben gesehen dass man
Kinder untersuchen kann ohne sie in
Narkose zu legen weil die Kinder aus der
Röhre heraus ihre Eltern sehen können es
ist ein Projekt
diej des deutschen zukunftspreises
überzeugt hat und den Bundespräsidenten
beeindruckt sie haben im Grunde genommen
die bisherige Entwicklung auf den Kopf
gestellt der Preis ist mit 250 000€
dotiert ein zusätzlicher Lohn für die
jahrelange Forschung zugunsten einer
besseren medizinischen Versorgung
weltweit zum Zukunftspreis heute um
2215 wenigis verdächtig war das Spiel
der Fußballnationalmannschaft gestern 0
Z2 gegen Österreich ja und erneut eine
desolate Mannschaftsleistung der
nagelsmanne Effekt völlig verpufft das
Team hilflos ratlos emotionslos und am
Ende torlos das letzte Testspiel des
Jahres sorgt für Kater statt für
ausbruchstimmung ins heimem Jahr
2024 beim Aufbruch aus Wien steht
Deutschlands Nationalspielern die
Enttäuschung über das am Vorabend
erlebte noch in den Gesichtern
geschrieben wobei Kevin tra noch am
ehesten überzeugt hatte Österreichs Sieg
wäre ohne ihn höhhe ausgefallen die
deutsche Defensivarbeit erneut schwach
im Hinblick auf die anstehende em macht
Bundestrainer nagelsmann sich keine
Illusionen es wird hier im Hinblick
Richtung Sommer nichts leicht von Hand
gehen das müssen man akzeptieren das ist
extrem viel Arbeit bissiger in die
Zweikämpfe gehen wäre schon mal ein
Anfang warum die deutschen Marcel
sabizza vor dessen Führungstreffer gar
nicht ernsthaft attackieren ein echtes
Rätsel die Mannschaft von Ralf Rangnick
in allen Belangen überlegen dann auch
noch die Unbeherrschtheit lirous SN ist
kurz nach dem Wechsel nach völlig
berechtigter roter Karte kassiert sein
Team in Unterzahl durch Baumgartner noch
den Treffer zum 2:0 Endstand ein
wahrhaft deprimierender Abend für
nagelsmanns
Auserwählte ja fragen wir unseren
Fußballexperten Thomas gulski ja was nun
was tun bis zur heimem nächsten Sommer
also die Fans zurückgewinnen wird man
nur wenn der Bundestrainer die beiden
gravierendsten Probleme löst da ist zum
einen die Mannschaft mit ihrer fehlenden
gear mit ihrer unerklärlichen Passivität
mit fehlender Leidenschaft aber dieses
Problem ist ja nicht neu und vielleicht
sogar unlösbar es sei denn der
Bundestrainer bringt mehr Mentalität auf
dem Platz mehr Spieler die bereit sind
die Ärmel hochzukrempeln und da ist zum
anderen der Bundestrainer selbst der
sein Versprechen gebrochen hat vom
Amtsantritt einfach wollte er es halten
die Mannschaft nicht überfordern aber
das Gegenteil hat er getan mit einer
verunsicherten Mannschaft die schlichte
fußballerische Einfachheit gebraucht
hätte leidplanken die Sicherheit geben
stattdessen hat er eine verunsicherte
Mannschaft nur noch weiter verunsichert
und deshalb steht die deutsche
Fußballnationalmannschaft jetzt wieder
da wo sie am Ende der ERA Flick
angekommen war danke für diese
Einschätzung danke Thomas gutzki aber es
gibt ja auch positive Nachrichten im
deutschen Fußball das
U21 Team das hat in der
emqualie gegen Polen gewonnen die Gäste
zunächst besser hier die Führung durch
Ariel mossur danach dreht Deutschland
das Spiel Merlin röl schließlich mit dem
Treffer zum 3:1 Endstand das dfbteam
jetzt sogar
Tabellenführer und bei der U17 WM steht
das deutsche Team nach dem 3:2 gegen die
USA sogar im Viertelfinale ja wunderbar
das macht doch Hoffnung J fehen noch die
Lottozahlen sie lauten 3 4 20 25 30 41
und die Superzahl 9 weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf
lotto.zf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
557 Obacht beim Wetter in der Nacht
gibt's gefrierenden Regen und morgen
gibt's Sturm die Details hat gleich
östen terli das heutejournal mit
Marietta slomker um :4 Uhr wir wünschen
noch einen schönen Abend bis morgen wenn
Sie mögen
[Musik]
tschüss schön guten Abend und Herr
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter aus
unterschiedlichen Richtungen kommen die
Tiefs auf uns zu haben aber eines
gemeinsam sie bringen Kaltluft mit
einmal dieses Tief was von Norden kommt
auf seiner Rückseite kommt hier die
Kaltluft zu uns und dann dieses Tief
hier was vom Schwarzen Meer nach Norden
zieht bringt immer noch die Kaltluft aus
dem Norden das bedeutet in den nächsten
Tagen gibt's Schnee vor allem am
Alpenrand wir schauen in die Nacht und
da wird es gefährlich glatt im Osten
Deutschlands hier kommt gefrierender
Regen auf ein paar Schneeflocken
ansonsten nimmt der Wind aus West en zu
und wird durchaus kräftig teils
stürmisch im Süden bildet sich Nebel die
Temperaturen frostig kalt bis -5° an den
Alpen und 6° ganz im Nordwesten aber sie
sehen hier häufig Minuswerte ja und
morgen dann kommt eine Kaltfront von
Norden her mit Regen dazu auch Sturmböen
ganz im Süden merkt man erstmal nichts
davon da gibt's Sonnenschein und diese
Kaltfront wandert allmählich dann weiter
südwärts das bei Temperaturen bis 13°
ganz im Nordwesten sonst im sü bei 4 bis
8° und die nächsten Tage ja am Freitag
kommen Schauer und graupelgewitter von
Norden her was 3 bis 9° danach wird's
noch etwas kälter und Schnee vor allem
an den Alpen schönen Abend